dr. strange is the latest character from
Marvel's back catalogue that the
studio's hoping to turn into big
cash-money and while they've made a
habit of making big dollar dollar from
their B C and D teams that success
wasn't always guaranteed sure characters
like Iron Man and Captain America are
big names but it was clear at least at
the time they were announced that Joe
and Jane public and their fictional kids
Billy and Betty who I've literally just
made up didn't have the foggiest clue
who guardians of the galaxy the Winter
Soldier or even ant-man were and yet
Marvel made a cool two billion dollars
from those characters so they must have
done something right probably because of
this inspired marketing a marvel
trolling us I mean I genuinely can't
tell anymore and so we come to Marvel's
latest reach into our pockets Doctor
Strange one of their more esoteric
creations but who exactly is the
sorcerer supreme well apart from his
skills as a neurosurgeon he's also the
most powerful wizard in the cosmos a
practitioner of both the mystical and
martial arts and generally one of the
stranger characters in the Marvel roster
and now as we all know he's getting his
own movie where he's played by British
thespian Benedict Cumberbatch a movie
the Marvel are marketing with amongst
other things
seriously Marvel can do literally
anything and we'll go watch their movies
so while those were the top-line facts
about the doc terrify things you might
not know about Stephen strange
this modern hospital may seem worlds
apart in the days of ancient sorcerers
what four psychiatrist Steven strange in
his beautiful patient this is where
those worlds collided and the nightmare
begins 2016's Doctor Strange is not the
good doctor's first movie outing and no
were not including 2014's brief name
drop in Captain America Winter Soldier
Stephen strange anyone who's a threat to
Hydra no instead we're talking about the
full-blown 93-minute CBS made-for-tv
movie that aired in 1978
it featured Lucille Bluth from Arrested
Development as evil sorceress Morgan la
Fey and Peter Putin Putin anyone know as
the psychiatrist turned sorcerer supreme
Stephen strange have I become the
sorcerer no you should probably check
out the trailer on YouTube because it is
genuinely incredible the Doctor Strange
TV movie was supposed to act as a pilot
to set up a whole series like the other
Marvel TV shows that CBS were airing at
the time like The Amazing Spiderman and
The Incredible Hulk but sadly it just
was never meant to be for Doctor Strange
on the small screen as the TV series was
never picked up by the network
even stranger maybe getting ready to go
on some adventures with the Avengers in
the MCU but in the comic book world he's
never actually been a card-carrying
member of the core team yes they have a
club card it's called The Avengers
IDenticard and it's loyalty program gets
you discounts on groceries probably
before you get your underoos in a twist
yes we know he was a member of the New
Avengers but that doesn't count since it
was pretty much a team made up of
whoever wasn't killed off in Civil War
one team Doctor Strange was part of
however is the defenders in fact he was
a founding member of it if the named
defenders is ringing some bells it might
be because that's the banner that
daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage and
iron fist will unite under in Marvel's
Netflix universe the defenders first
appeared in 1971 with Doctor Strange
Hulk and Namor the Submariner on the
team later on Silver Surfer also joined
among others their popularity has
endured and as recent as this year
Doctor Strange assembled the secret
defenders to fight alongside him Doctor
Strange has an extensive history of
leading his own team and while the
defenders name might be taken by the
Marvel Netflix Cinematic Universe we
wouldn't be surprised to see him put
together his own mystical team in the
big screen MCU
the world we know in the MCU isn't the
only one that exists in the Marvel canon
in fact there's an infinite number of
Marvel Universe is all existing within
the comics and Doctor Strange has
featured in some of the very weirdest
there's one where dr. strangers a
crocodile called crocked a strange and
even one where he is an advisor to Queen
Elizabeth the first in this regal
timeline Doctor Strange is now sir dr.
Stephen strange the Queen's personal
physician and master of the Queen's
medicines which might just be too many
titles for your average business card in
this reality or in the year 1602 Tudor
England and the world as they know it
has been plagued by some peculiar
weather blood red skies earthquakes
rains and lizards you know classic
British weather after Queen Elizabeth's
death the new king james imprison
strange and beheaded him for treason his
wife Claire took her husband's head from
the pike had been impaled on
communicated with it and then fled to
America since he was no longer alive he
was freed to spiritually communicate
away to save the world to his wife and
once the earth was saved from the lizard
reins his head was allowed to return to
his body in the crypt they just love
happy endings Stephen strange and Tony
Stark are two sides of the same coin
they both defend the earth against
cataclysmic threats but while one deals
in Science and Technology the other one
deals in magic and mysticism the pair
disagree all the time often because Tony
Stark simply can't get on board with the
idea that there are things in the
universe he just can't explain they
frequently clash over the use of their
unique ability to solve their problems
with Ironman dismissing magic as
make-believe and dr. strange seeing
technology as of limited applicability
in his fantastical corner of the
universe but there's a good-natured
rivalry between them while were yet to
see how strange will fit into the larger
MCU there's ample opportunity to have
some fun with their relationship and
create some friendly banner Marvel comic
fans have demanded the awesome facial
hair bro gag be recreated in live-action
and we're inclined to agree I mean who
doesn't want to see Robert Downey jr.
and Benedict Cumberbatch high five in
honor of their goatees of course there's
also the opportunity to introduce the
loominatee
no not that Illuminati I'm talking about
the other one
you know the secret organization made up
of the world's most powerful superheroes
who meet in secret to pull the strings
behind the biggest superhero teams and
discuss the fate of world actually been
all that different from each other
anyway
the MTU currently has three members of
the Illuminati in play
Iron Man Doctor Strange and black
panther unfortunately the other two
Professor X and Fantastic Four's Reed
Richards are beyond reach since their
movie licenses are over a 20th Century
Fox but they can easily be replaced with
Black Bolt who could be introduced in
Marvel's Inhumans movie and Namor who
totally deserves his own spin-offs and
it would certainly be a great way to
develop the relationship between stock
and strange in the MCU Doctor Strange
fans will already know that he takes
residence in a lovely three-story
townhouse that he calls his sanctum
sanctorum it's a lovely building right
in the heart of Greenwich Village with
the exact address being 177 a Bleecker
Street in the comics the house is an
epicenter of magic with a history that
reads like an estate agents worst
nightmare it was originally a site for
pagan sacrifices then the land was
cursed by a shaman and somewhere in
there
Native American Indians used the space
to cast rituals and at one point it was
gonna become a Starbucks because what
isn't these days while the outside of
the sanctum may look small it's on the
inside that counts
an inside it's packed full of
labyrinthine corridors and rooms that
seem to change sides at will a bit like
the TARDIS but with better furnishings
or you might not know is that 1/7 of an
a Bleecker Street Greenwich Village New
York City is actually a real place
although I don't think it's the secret
headquarters for the New Avengers or the
defenders in fact it looks like an
apartment block stuck in between a
grocery store and a tattoo parlor or
maybe it's the perfect disguise
so there we are
five strange facts about dr. strange for
more videos like this one make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to GameSpot don't be
a strange earth we'll see you next week